What would happen if we were to designate a very,
very powerful nuclear weapon on the moon,
would the explosion knock its orbit towards earth causing tidal waves and
misery, could the moon be destroyed?
Showering the earth in a rain of meteoric death.
[Inaudible].
During the cold war,
the moon was a major target for space exploration and you know, military basis.
So the us air force commissioned a serious study into the effects of a nuclear
designation on the surface of the moon, but just quoting stuff is boring.
So let's conduct a very important scientific experiment with an imaginary 100
megaton thermonuclear warhead about twice as powerful as the most powerful bomb
ever.
Detonators will also place a number of curious astronauts around the moon.
As observers let's push the button and slow down time
for the first few milliseconds, nothing much happens outside our weapon.
Meanwhile,
inside high explosives send a shockwave to a radioactive metal core,
compressing it so much that it reaches criticality and starts a nuclear
efficient chain reaction.
The 100 million degree plasma created in this first stage sets off the second
stage with atomic nuclei,
fusing like they do in the core of a star very briefly,
how weapon contains one of the hottest places in the universe,
and only now barely 10 milliseconds later does the rest of the universe find out
that anything has happened as suddenly the bomb dissolves and the flaming star
of nuclear death is born so far so good,
but everything that happens now is very different from what we're used to on
earth, because of one major difference. There's no atmosphere.
As the fireball shines, it releases a flash of x-rays and thermal photons,
a wave of silent heat,
which rushes outwards in all directions on earth vis heat will char and
burn everything within a 50 kilometer radius, at least,
but on the moon without an atmosphere and oxygen rich air,
there's no burning at all. Also, there are no things to burn.
The crunchy top side of the moon is made from silicate rock and metals chew to
dust by eons of meteorite impacts mixed with tiny traces of water.
When heated by the explosion,
x-rays from the fireball vaporizer thin cloud of rock from the lunar surface
while the unlucky dust that's inside the fireball melt center glass and he
astronauts washing the soap within about 50 kilometers can expect to be fried.
And now we begin to see one of the biggest differences between explosions in
space and on earth on earth.
The atmosphere fights back against the plasma bubble.
Its expansion is violently stomped within moments by the pressure of the
atmosphere, but this is not good news. As the fireball Rams,
the atmosphere,
it produces the most destructive part of a nuclear explosion on earth.
The shockwave compressed air around the explosion rushes out faster than the
speed of sound, shattering buildings and roaring so loud. It ruptures organs,
but on the moon, there is no shockwave.
No atmosphere means nothing to impede the expanding explosion in space on
the moon.
The fireball just grows in airy silence as there's no atmosphere to stop it or
to give to voice. This would be an amazing thing to watch from a safe distance.
Unfortunately,
there's hardly any safe viewing distance for a nuclear explosion on the moon,
without an atmosphere weakening the deadly ionizing radiation that can scramble
DNA. Anyone close enough to get a good look will be exposed to fatal amounts of
radiation. But of course that's not all while all of this happens.
The explosion hammers against the moon,
transferring about a 10th of the explosion, energy into seismic waves,
powering and intense moon quake.
The moon is much smaller than the earth and our astronauts will feel an
inescapable, violent shaking,
no matter where they're standing comparable to an earthquake of seven on the
ratio scale, this shaking could seriously damage or even level infrastructure.
We might've built anywhere on the moon.
Those who hit on the first side of the moon would have no idea.
It was an explosion. The quaking would feel like an asteroid.
The size of the great pyramid had struck,
and it's not over yet where our bomb explodes.
The ground splatters like water.
When a rock strikes upon as the explosion pushes against the surface,
it may excavate as much as a hundred million cubic meters of Dustin rock forming
a crater eight kilometer across while bedrock is pulverized to rubble.
Debris is shot into the sky in every direction. Again, without an atmosphere,
there's no drag to slow any of it down. Much of the debris scattered,
never returns to the moon flying off at faster than escape velocity.
A flurry of micrometeorites have been cast off to explore the soda system.
Many of which will rain down on the earth though.
Few will be larger than pebbles.
Any satellite astronauts or space station in the way though,
we'll have a really bad time.
Micrometeorites are launched at many speeds and angles,
allowing them to spread all over the surface of the moon,
like bullets they'll punch through our curious astronauts,
no matter where they stand. Finally,
our explosion comes to an end on earth.
The fireball rises like a hot air balloon forming a sort of stalk as it reaches
up. Cooler air is drawn in around it, rounding the top into a mushroom clouds,
but on the moon. Well, you know, by now no atmosphere, no mushroom,
the larger the plasma gets the cooler it becomes and the less energy it has to
make interesting or terrifying things happen within seconds of putting the
trigger, the bubble reddens and fades from view,
it would be visible from the earth like a star flickering to life only to fade
out right away, a spark,
and then nothing as the cloud of tiny debris reaches far above the surface of
the moon. It's illuminated by the sun for a few minutes,
giving us an airy beauty for anyone left to observe the spectacle.
What about the moon's orbit?
It's basically unchanged trying to move the moon with a nuke.
It's like trying to move a truck by blowing on it.
Nuclear explosions may be big, but space is bigger.
Our mighty explosion just leaves another traitor. One among millions,
still anyone on the moon will continue to not enjoy themselves.
The material that ends up writing back to the moon is radioactive and without
any natural processes to wash it away or barriers,
the surface of the moon will remain contaminated. Although fortunately,
the worst of the radiation will have decayed to a level comparable to natural
levels from cosmic rays in about a year in conclusion,
we can say with confidence that while the moon itself does not care about being
mute and we'll barely notice using the moon as a nuclear test ground kind
of ruins it for everyone trying to spend some time there or to build something
useful. So maybe we should just not do that.
This was our last video of the year, 12,020, and, uh, ODL.
Wasn't interesting in where Jared's been in all the worst ways,
but it's finally over. We want to end it by saying thank you.
We get to do this channel and work on many exciting things because of you burbs
this year, our German channel reached a million subscribers.
We launched our Spanish one and released our first app.
If everything goes well,
we can finally start our largest new project to date next year,
but we know better than to promise too much.
All of this works because you support us directly. Thank you so much.
We genuinely appreciate it.
If you want to help us out too and get something cool in return to the tune of
nuking, the moon,
we've made a new minimalistic infographic poster about the moon and how
incredibly far away it is also. There's a baby duck, our cutest plushy.
Yes, a new duck and friends, enamel mug, our new ocean Explorer notebook,
and so much more all made with love and care.
Let us know what you like and we'll make more of it. Okay.
Let's wrap up this video and this year,
thank you again for watching and caring and sharing.
We hope that you slide peacefully into the year 12,021.
Let's all hope. It will be a really.
Yeah.